we work diligently in the ministry and
rejoice today and I know that's a strong
world because I know for back then he
knew the Lord it's hard enough to deal
with what life is taken remember but we
had a relationship
[Music]
then you know as rough as it is and
that's difficult as it is that death is
not there that was in Christ Jesus it
shall also quicken your body to everyone
I'm grateful for you I'm grateful for
community that has the compassion of the
love that we were thought to come
together at a time like this and show
that we are closely knit together and
that we love one another and that we
will hold one another oh I know that
they're going to be having all kinds of
services during the week and next
weekend it's going to seem as though
it's never-ending
I encourage you to make your presence
known beyond these next two years the
Hampton Roads equipment Auckland Council
of Bishops what also holds the community
on Sunday June the 9th at 7 p.m. we have
partnered with grace bible church and
pastor Eric Sampson and the unity
project of Virginia so many other
organizations that we will come together
again to share reflections of to share
and share our strength but do this
remember that we are in the inner circle
of divine love and life and all is well
and underneath are the everlasting arms
the grace means and strength of the Lord
[Music]
[Applause]
we convince father we come before you
see coming into the presence of the
flavors
oh but right now call upon you go gotta
go
half the state just as we can choose
from Baba
yeah oh god we I was simple to hear this
evening oh by from various neighborhoods
follow from various levels of city
government from various levels oh god of
government about this baby to come to be
together in one another's presence so
that all the translation to these fans
will battle over the impact that we
actually write down to let you hold it
and
Oh God right now somebody's week
somebody right now that needs to know
that your presence is right there in
there Michael
because Oh God this family is blindsided
sign somebody the bottom thought this
would be just another summer weekend the
whole like [ __ ] somebody oh god we just
[ __ ] the light oh I got a wake-up call
Stanley born into the ship assistance
both I we need you right now we need you
right now who's got to get them so much
food that we eat your mercy we need your
mercy oh god show up at this glacial
Valley and give us a reprieve from this
gun violence give us the real people not
from the atmosphere this nation of god
that allows life to but we take it
unchallenged and uncharged it was a
reprieve Oh God from from those of that
who was suffering such we've got they
would take their suffering and dispersed
among the innocent
we need you person God can be equated
with a good grace
we become video God that is full of
diversity a studio movie are people that
we need to be just have you awaken our
community so that allow us to know by
the despite the difficulties in the days
ahead that you will still be right by
our side spilling down but still holding
the sample go as only your spirit into
god this is a community we'll all have
been impacted that regardless of
Krishna's denomination they garden some
secular choice regardless of either
today is about fish to get a guy we've
all been impacted no kindest man need of
your glory and offenses that would come
with eternal terrible of the forest
[Music]
in a state that can preserve a lot of
life without it need not use distress
dictated or God we come here God to lift
the families but oh god we were missing
we do take the opportunity allowed to
see who we are in faith we are a people
of God and we are we are tired of seeing
our loved ones gunned down throughout
the state
we're tired of God above the same most
rainbow of violence in and out crying
and then prayer them back to the same
goals that again that we need something
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
right now become how about the spiritual
agenda as you go back to the municipal
spend all money as you go back to
Richmond on Monday the agenda go and we
shall remember May 31st 2019 ow
[Applause]
to give a reflection spa my prayer by
Rabbi Israel
and here a pastor playing the loved one
Sandhya's evenly although God is
privileged to have microphone a week
with those we
yeah on with those and I said earlier
this morning in our congregation god I
don't know what to say
I don't know how to say I don't know how
to breathe in the box but I don't know
what to say I know hungry and some type
of understanding and so I my reflection
it's not get out of one of the disguise
this moment I don't want to get up and
talk about things on the left or the
right and I'm thankful that we have all
these creatures behind me who will who
will share those things but I stand just
to share what God's Word works shares
with us the New Living Translation of
2nd Corinthians chapter 4 verse 8 and 9
say this we are breath
but we are not crushed we are perplexed
but not driven this is this faith we are
hunted down but never abandoned by God
we did knocked down but we are not
destroyed
did Paul ended up in verse 16 he says
that is why we never give up though our
bodies I died our spirits I think we're
dude every day for our present troubles
I small it won't last very long yet they
produce for us our glory they vastly
outweighs them and will last whatever so
we don't look and what we did see right
we don't fix eyes on what we're going
through we fix eyes on the things that
we cannot see but they exactly see right
the only temporary
that won't last always but we keep our
faith and hope and those things which we
cannot see but that will last me but
Jesus we will remember we will rise we
will go forward in vain I Hertz will be
bless you the question is asked what do
we do how can we do what is it
[Applause]
my god
[Applause]
but
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's
[Music]
Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]